we're just going to break out of this
now just to bring you some breaking news
coming in from the U.S Islamic State
militants convicted of plotting to
behead U.S hostages has been sentenced
to life in prison he was of course found
guilty back in April let's go straight
now to the US now to David Blevins our
correspondent who can tell us more David
what more can you tell us
yes El Shafi El Sheikh a 33 year old
british-born jihadist was convicted back
in April on eight coins including lethal
hostage taking and conspiracy to murder
he's now been sentenced to life without
parole and will spend the rest of his
life in prison therefore the court heard
during a 15-day trial that he was one of
three Islamic jihadists described by
their hostages as the Beatles because of
their English accents Alexander Cote who
was convicted on similar charges earlier
this year was another member of that
group and the third known as Jihadi John
Mohammed imwazi was killed in a drone
strike so they were they came to
prominence because of this term The
Beatles and now two of them have been
fined guilty and have been sentenced I
think the most dramatic thing that
happened today was hearing Victim Impact
statements from families particularly
the mother of the journalist James Foley
whose murder I think brought Isis to the
attention of the world she said that El
Sheikh had chosen hatred over Humanity
love is so much stronger than hit she
said I pity you because you've chosen
hatred and succumbed to a false theology
because Islam is a Theology of justice
and she said her son James Foley who
died eight years ago today is more alive
than ever in his mother his father his
brother his sister and in the
journalists who continue to tell his
story around the world so just to recap
33 year old El Shafi El Sheikh a
british-born jihadist sentenced to life
on eight counts including conspiracy to
murder and lethal hostage taking